cafe de coming for you what's up siege
fans we recently went hands-on with
rainbow 6 siege is season 3 content
including two new operators the new
favela map and the new tactical realism
mode I'd like to start off by saying
that I think the operators should
probably be flipped but I'll get to that
in a second the new attacker is Cappy
tell his intended design is to dislodge
defenders with a crossbow the fires
incendiary and micro smoke arrows I was
initially worried that his crossbow was
his primary weapon but it's not it's a
special ability and it's great for a
number of things including area-denial
think keeping defenders away from an
objective you just armed good for
burning defenders hunkering behind
corners and good for situational
awareness thank shooting into a room and
looking for hit markers the new defender
kuvira is designed to hunt down loose
attackers and make them pay for straying
from the group unfortunately she has to
get those attackers into a downstate
before doing the interrogation which can
be a bit tricky her silent step seems
pretty useful on larger maps where she
can flank but not as much on tight maps
for being spotted isn't worth the risk
of losing your primary weapon and sneaky
interrogation spot the entire attacking
team who then become easy pickings for
aggressive defenders now your location
what I can do
so here's why I think this is backwards
we're in the more dominant strategies
hurting siege at the moment are running
gun defensive roamers who stray away
from the objective they're supposed to
defend and ambush attacking teams from
behind the roaming phenomenon takes away
from the tactical nature of the game and
punishes slow and cautious attackers
recent patches that made cap cans laser
trap more dangerous by removing it
stealth and the addition of a newer
operator frost who has bear traps have
only Sloane down attackers more in favor
of defenders if caviar had been on the
attacking side it would have vastly
increased the risk of loose roaming
defenders who could have been downed and
interrogated on the other end Kappa
Tau's LMG and area-denial capabilities
would have been best suited for holding
attackers at bay and burning time off
the clock the new map favela is a new
close quarters addition probably about
the size of to Hereford bases put
together and features a lot of exterior
destruction this means defenders are
more likely to break exterior walls and
shoot attackers on approach but also
attackers are more likely to use drone
spotting and kill defenders through
walls this design ups the danger for
both teams and leads to some pretty
tense moments
finally we saw the new hardcore mode
called tactical realism we had a short
time with it and it was total
pandemonium with no friend or foe HUD
elements there was a lot of team killing
but there's a plus side to that because
after a while the team killing force
teams to stick together with sieges more
recent head customization it's going to
be even more difficult for players to
identify who they're shooting at on
release my favorite part of tactical
realism was the lack of crosshair and
that's it if you haven't made up your
mind yet we've got some clean gameplay
up for your viewing pleasure on gamespot
and youtube thanks for watching for land
operator for neutralized information
successful